okay son not too bad red sauce Luton
galaxy I don't know what that means but
okay good one bar try
all right you dumb baby stay in the
basket or else you're not gonna get
dessert anymore oh just fine oh you have
a harpoon in your ha okay we're together
forever and so not my love a francais
Francois Timmy attack Oh Oh God just
leave it alone kid Kansas you have it
pain they're coming for me no no Morgan
you are I this Chinese again nope Oh to
my chest but it'll be a good weapon
against your friends who cares it again
today
all right over the head oh so pro went
thread through my door oh ok so far so
good
I'm goddamn boy that's a heartburn oh
that is
okay goodbye Jimmy oh it's your friends
we're having a good time bridges of doom
why are they bridges of duel you say oh
I get it cause they're people about to
die oh I get it okay okay that was a
little walkie well where'd my son go he
is now dead I'm on my own freedom where
am I Rolf's Wingmaster
well as you can see my my backwards
somersault Oh
so dad killed JP with portal red stands
for Sun it stands for polluting what
does pollutant mean this made donker
dick plonker Punk stonker franck
Oh No lost my son what am I gonna do
walk dope I know [ __ ] to me oh look I
won I'm the best ah war throw but only
one understand Conan's little hugs
rustled poetic Knicks trophies will make
good meet them editor clackum okay then
oh why is that happening uh they came
back on me and I have a double sword
what does it mean okay hi there all
right you could ease we were assigned
the task of killing say be all mustang
to killing loneliness attorneys McGraw
here we go
oh if I could just carry on I'd be so
down like an arrow like a green arrow no
I'm fine okay
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye